Is there a big advantage to drinking greens first throughout the day?
I've taken to mixing it in the morning and using it to wash down my morning supplements and finishing it
I'll stop if that's not good
So there's a there's a lot of nutrients in greens first and if you're just taking it in the morning remember I
Don't think that's wrong. So I wouldn't say you should stop doing that
But remember all your supplements any supplements you take in any nutrients you get from food have a half-light
So if you're taking everything you're supposed to be taking in the morning and you're not taking anything all day long
Well, that stuff is all gone from you and it's doing you no good by the end of the day. So can it be good years ago? I used to
Have people when I give them the recipe for the drink. I'd say you have to sip it all day long
The problem is people would just complain about that. It's getting warm. I don't like it. I firm through it. I firm finish it
It's a moment. So I don't necessarily say that anymore, but I think it's
It would be good to maybe swallow all your supplements with water and then have your green drink
That you take a few hours to consume. I
Just know that doesn't fit everybody's lifestyle. So
When I make a great drink, it's usually gone within a half an hour, but I
There's no way I can
Just too much of a pig I think I don't know
I'm not sure if my lesions are speckled. Did you get that from the MRI findings? I
Looked at your MRI a couple weeks ago. So I
I just remember
That they were diff it was diffuse. I could be wrong. I'll look at that again tomorrow though. So
Send me an email if you need to remind me
You don't need to send me the images. Well, let me look at what the radiologist said and then I'll email you tomorrow